very much jay for your time today i
really appreciate it and i'll
turn it over to you
thank you rachel let me quickly share my
screen
all right perfect so my name is jessing
i work
in cvs aetna aetna is a big health
insurance company here in the u.s
and we were acquired by cvs which is a
big pharmacy company here
also in the us i work in data science
i've been in
insurance for the last six years and
i've been in data science for more than
a decade
based out of boston and today i will be
talking to you guys
about how we have been using shiny to
build up
these uh rapid prototyping frameworks
which help us take data science and
operationalize it
uh and i'll be showing you some of the
apps that
we have been using in our day-to-day
working
but before i begin as always a quick
advertisement
if you are looking for a new job or if
you are interested in opportunities with
in data science please do consider us we
are a fortune 5 company
one of the five biggest companies here
in the u.s great benefits
work-life balance the other thing is
that executives
uh they have a very strong data hole
they love
making decisions based on data that's
why there's a lot of visibility
on data science and we are hiring very
uh very rapidly all across the u.s if
you are interested
in opportunities anywhere in the u.s to
contact us we are hiring from all
different roles
from analysts all the way up to senior
directors
and if you're interested you can always
google cvs
data science and you look at the
opportunities but a better way is just
email me
and i can shortcut you through through
most of the process
and get you and get your foot in the
door pretty quickly with the interviews
so do consider us if you are looking to
make a switch or if you're
interested in data science at uh cbs at
now
all right so rapid prototyping
essentially is taking whatever analysis
you're doing
and if you feel like you will do it more
than twice then you build
a web app out of it and this tends to
help you in
in a lot of different ways one of the
biggest things it helps you with is that
now you can share the minimum viable
product with a bunch of different people
and they can iterate through it
and that'll help you get the most
efficient and optimized analysis
and it makes it it's very reputable you
can make a github page
but if you make a shiny app it's easier
for people who are not
r or python or just in general sas users
to play with your analysis and quickly
get
uh to the end point faster so it
standardizes a lot of it so that's why
rapid prototyping you would see that
it's it's a very common theme in
different uh
industry paradigms people in statistics
will be familiar with chris dm which is
cross industry standard process for data
mining
where you start with the data you
perform
data pre-processing you build a model
you evaluate how well the model is
working you deploy it
and then usually you go back to the
business and they tell you everything
you've done is completely wrong and you
start from scratch so
crisp dm design thinking agile you'll
see
they're all very circular and
essentially what they're trying to do is
get to the minimum viable product
faster and then test and learn and to do
this you can use all these different
frameworks
in data science you can build web
applications
and if you look at the history of web
applications uh it started with the
html in the 1990s probably some
lonely grad student in uh in some
computer science department made this up
probably not and then over the years you
saw that
it has evolved and now we got in close
to 2000 we got these web applications
made
in java in 2014 we got our shiny which
changed a lot of
how web apps are made uh it was
developed by a chochang
and essentially it removes you
from trying to have expertise in html
css and js
and you can actually build your
applications which are data science
heavy
and you can make them uh with an
interface which is very very pretty
a gui which looks good and easy to
navigate
now over the few years now you have a
bunch of different web app
tool frameworks like flask dash
streamlit
but i still prefer shiny and i'll tell
you why
now there are trade-offs so you can
consider
building your web applications in
different frameworks
so you can use flask which is python
based and you can sort of mix
last with javascript uh to make a web
application this is
throughout a lot of different companies
especially if you see things on
websites this is they use it with django
uh and this is this is the way they use
most of the web applications dash is
pretty popular
tableau is more for dashboarding and i'm
sure you guys are aware of
how tableau dashboards have been made
and employed throughout the world
and then obviously there are shiny then
you can compare
all of these different frameworks on all
of these different measures
the three ones that i find very
important are
just stack overflow support so if you
are a data scientist
you know how much how important it is
for you to have support and be able to
find help online
and i find that shiny tends to have a
lot of help online just because it was
the first to market
a lot of people have failed doing the
same things
that you are trying to do so that tends
to help it is popular with data
scientists just because r
is one of the two biggest languages for
data science
uh you will speak the same language and
somebody who comes after you will be
able to maintain the apps that you have
created
and finally it's free of cost which is
pretty important you don't want to play
three thousand dollars for a software
package uh
which in the end if it does if it
doesn't add
to the free tools that are out there
then you've essentially uh
cost the company 3000 bucks so that's
one one one of the
one of the areas where i think shiny
tends to
shine or do very well overall now
if you're not familiar with when do you
use web apps
which i highly doubt if you're in this
meetup
then uh you would use web apps when you
want to revisit
the same code for different projects so
if you're trying to do something similar
over the different projects you can make
a web out
out of it if you want to introduce a new
technique i've seen this work pretty
well
one of the apps that i'll show you today
is the comorbidity analysis which is
a technique that i had published a paper
in academia
but wasn't used in industry too often
and making a web app
tends to help with that it it leads to
faster adoption of whatever you're
trying to sell
and finally the most critical one is if
you're trying if there is an analysis
that you do that has multiple steps
and that analysis is pretty common so
multiple groups within
your organization are are using a
similar framework
and then getting different answers or
different variations of the same answer
and then presenting it to the business
this leads to a lot of confusion
so if you standardize your whole data
science process and you build a web app
that everybody can use then that tends
to shorten the time to analysis
and it also helps in standardization
overall
and usually web apps are more useful
when you need
slightly more than just dashboarding if
you just need dashboarding then the best
things are power bi
and tableau
so what do you do when you're trying to
make a decision on whether you should
build
a web application in-house or should you
outsource it to somebody else
now there are seven now there are
several different things you can
consider
uh cost so if you're trying to buy it
that is you're trying to get somebody
else to build it for you from outside
the org
it will be more costly the
customizations
you might be able to get some
customizations but more additional
customizations will cost you even more
and then the biggest one is knowledge
gain you will not have the knowledge
gain somebody else will
it'll save you on man hours build time
and support
if you build it in-house which shiny
allows you to do
build these uh rapid prototyping
frameworks in-house very quickly
then it will be cheap essentially it'll
be free will only be the manners that
the data scientist requires it'll be
very customized
and you will have knowledge gain it will
take some time
for your department to build these apps
and you are the support if you build the
app
obviously it requires majority of your
time so these are some of the downsides
of whether you should be building an app
or you should be
buying uh a solution from from outside
all right having said that today i will
show you some of the apps that i have
built
for cvs and how have they how have they
been used
uh some of the different ones are the
first one that i'll show you is called
the clustering and profiling app it's a
web application that does
market segmentation which is pretty
standard you're trying to find
groups of people that are similar to
each other
in in a diverse population i'll show you
a comorbidity analysis app which is uh
useful for finding comorbidities now
in health insurance or in health care
comorbidities are when you have
one more than one health condition so
suppose you have diabetes and
hypertension
then you have two conditions so it's a
comorbidity
i'll show you a propensity score
matching app so this comes from causal
inference
so if you do not have a randomized
control trial so
it's not randomized so you have to do
quasi experimental methods
like matching essentially what you're
trying to do is create a synthetic
control group
and to find these controls who are
similar to your
test group you have to match them on
different criteria the different
features and to do that you can use this
app called propensity score matching app
this is more causal in prints
i'll also quickly show you the equal
tool that i built for
a competition within my company it's
called the competition was called avc
and they judged you on how innovative
your app was how much money will it save
the company and how good looking you are
so obviously i was in the top five uh
but what equal does is equal stands for
eliminate
quantitative unfair fairness in
algorithms now you might have heard of
how predictive models might be
propagating bias in algorithms
so because algorithms or models are
built on real life data
and if there is bias in in the data set
there are historical biases in the data
set
a model will not propagate them it'll
accentuate them
so because cvs is very big on fairness
and equality we have checked all our
models
to make sure that we are equal we are
fair and we are
unjust and this tool is being used to do
some of those things
we also have a topic modeling app that i
will not show you today which
uh uses nlp and it does uh some
topic modeling on notes that people get
from
from customer care all right
so the first app which is the clustering
and profiling app
the big problem was that multiple teams
were performing customer segmentation
and they were all using slightly
different uh methodologies
but slightly diff different variations
and they were getting
similar results but not quite and then
they were presenting it to different
business units
which was causing confusion confusion
and
this comes from the fact that people
have been trained in market segmentation
but everybody uses
a slightly different route they present
their results slightly differently
people are either r users python users
or sas users and they use different
variations they use different little
things like
imputations or capping they're
they're slightly different and the end
result tends to be
different this confuses everybody and in
the end
a department like marketing who's trying
to figure out what segments
exist in say a population in boston
uh if they get different answers from
different business units they have to
recalibrate
very often and this costs a lot of time
and money obviously so
this was the big problem that we were
facing
now the clustering and profiling app
helps you
get to clustering insights faster
it's a web application developed in um
in
our shiny uh at cvs health we have
an rstudio uh environment where you can
publish these apps we also have uh
support for python and sas
as well
and the way this app works is it uses
four steps
it performs exploratory data analysis it
does the actual clustering
it also gives you insight generation so
a look at your results
and it'll tell you what are the groups
how do they look like
uh it's again again it's agile framework
you can rapidly iterate through multiple
things you can change whatever you like
and this is mainly for people who are
familiar with clustering and how this
market segmentation analysis work it
it's not for people who have don't have
a background in data science because
then uh
these results can be they can get a
little confusing for you
and just to just to tell you how it has
changed the way we do
market segmentation before this app we
had to do a bunch of these different
steps
and now we can rapidly iterate on all of
these different steps
for example for eda we had to do all
these uh
missing data renaming and correlations
and now it's a once
click eda similarly we do similarly for
clustering profiling insight generation
summarization and even sub segment
analysis
it's now all semi-automated
and it it's way quicker now
right moving on to the app
all right so this is how the app looks
like you can come in you can take a
quick tour
which will introduce you to the
different uh
parts of the app essentially what you do
is
you can import your data you can explore
it so you can
explore your data get summaries missing
values correlations
you can find clusters in your data you
can use different methods for clustering
we use uh
we prefer create prototypes for mixed
data
you can then profile the clusters you
found so for example you found these
three different clusters in your data
set
then you can profile them you can you
can quickly
find that these clusters differ in age
and their risk
and then you can also get more detailed
insights you can find out what are the
key variables
that triage this risk so
the data consists of people who are
either below 50 or above 50
if they are below 50 they go in the
first cluster if they are not they can
be further bifurcated by risk
and then they can go into cluster 2 and
3. so you can use decision trees to
to form these clusters
to enable so the one thing that i've
learned by making these apps and
launching it to a small audience is
the more explanations you can give the
more intuitive it is the better
and that's why using javascript in here
for all of these uh
different uh helper little boxes
that tends to be very useful and just
giving them
uh directions up top it all it's very
useful for people who are not
very familiar with your app also
uploading a toy data set is highly
recommended if you've not
if you just directly put in and upload
your own data then
people get confused so i put in like
three or four different toy data sets
that you can
use uh from different sources i'll show
you
uh clinical data since i work for edna
so let's look at this data set which is
just it's fake
it is a data set of members with
different diseases
and different characteristics and you
can pick the different variables that
you want to include in your analysis
uh up here you can quickly
explore the data and get summaries you
can find
if what percentage of zeros exist within
your data set you can find what how many
uh different
what is the different types of factors
within
uh each variable and what kind of a
variable is it
and it'll give you like missing data
summaries as well now
this is pretty powerful you can quickly
get summaries you can download all of
this
in either of the formats that you want
so you if you want a pdf you quickly
download this as a pdf
and it'll give you all of these
summaries in whatever format
it'll show you correlations very quickly
you can find what are
the variables that are very correlated
with each other so if you spend
days in an inpatient facility you'll
obviously have very high medical costs
so that's that's why you have high
correlations
and you can view your raw data whatever
you have uploaded
uh also you might want to remove
variables which are very highly
correlated so then you can remove those
variables
right here going forward they'll be
excluded from the rest of the analysis
so this is how you explore data then you
can go into
uh the clustering analysis where you say
decide the number of clusters
a very common data science clustering
101
technique using the elbow method and
then you can
choose whatever whatever method you want
for your clustering algorithm
and just quickly click to cluster and
for example if you use three clusters
then it gives you this result
and you can also change clusters
according to business needs so if the
business says
three is too little we need something
between four to six and you
and if you've done this before you know
that market segmentation is not a pure
data science exercise it's a mix it's a
mix between what the business wants
and what you can give them so you can
very quickly iterate on what you want
also we've seen that the variables that
we have some of them are continuous and
some of them are categorical
sometimes you might want to weigh the
continuous variables a little more
things like age tend to have more
information in them
say age between 18 to 90 than binary
variables like
do you have a ferrari or not
so we do want to exploit the that that
higher information content in continuous
variables so you can
also play around with the uh
the weightage that you put on on the
different variable types
so for example we we chose three
clusters and these are the three
clusters that you got right now
you can download all the results at this
stage
or you can go on to the next part where
you get some more insights into
how your clusters look so this gives you
the distribution of clusters it'll
give you either the the count if it's a
binary variable say gender mail it's a
binary variable it'll
give you the count and the percentage so
59.3 percent of the members in the first
cluster
are male in the second cluster you have
55 percent of the members there are
males so more males
and in the last one it's more females
only 15
of them are males and will give you the
average risk or
what percentage of them have asthma so
six percent of cluster one have asthma
so this is giving you insights very
quickly what is more interesting in
is how they compare to each other which
is what we get in the next tab
now it will tell you for males the first
two clusters are very heavily male
the third one not so much com similarly
for age
the first two clusters are more older
the third one is younger
so now you can see very quickly you're
forming a profile for these clusters
you're
you're saying that the first two
clusters are male older the third
cluster is more female and younger
finally you can also get the profiles of
these clusters generated
so from the z-score that i've i was
showing here you can very quickly
find the top variables that define a
cluster so cluster one
tends to be people who are obese uh they
are either
they're more rural and they have
metabolic syndrome and so forth on
and if you go back and change your
clustering algorithm
all of this will change very quickly so
suppose
you wanted four clusters you think the
three clusters you have are not very
good
then you can just come back and very
quickly
change all of this results and you'll
have four clusters so you see
it rating through your data set now
becomes very easy it's very intuitive
so now you have your four clusters
you've done everything
and now you want to understand your
clusters this is where the decision tree
the cart algorithm comes in
and what we have done here is we've uh
we're trying to
build a decision tree trying to predict
what are the different clusters and how
do you get to them
so the different clusters are shown in
different colors so you have
cluster number one two class number
three
and cluster number four here and if you
have an inpatient score of greater than
35
age less than 59 then you will fall in
cluster number four
so now you've got the rules as well so
now you can identify
there are four clusters in my data and
these are the rules
uh that allow me to get to a population
which will be cluster number four
it'll give you variable importance based
on the cart model he'll also give you
the rules written out so it'll tell you
what percentage 36 percent of the
members will follow this rule
and so forth on so
this this tends to be very powerful
finally you're done with your analysis
what it does is now it download an
excel file with all the results and a
formatted powerpoint
so not only you've completed your
analysis it'll give you a formatted
aetna powerpoint with aetna of custom
fonts charts everything
so now you can just take this analysis
and show it to your business unit
and they would know what you are talking
about
and this tends to be very powerful
you've completed a segmentation exercise
in minutes which usually takes our
business units which were working alone
with either their own code and
iterating through different steps weeks
to do
just give show you how the final
powerpoint looks
so this is the final powerpoint that it
has downloaded it shows you all the
different steps it shows
how many clusters were found and so
forth on
the methodology that you used
finally we did put in a feedback form we
wanted to
learn from the audience and get better
so we're trying to measure things like
customer satisfaction score and net
promoter scores and also trying to
get more feedback on what what changes
would they want
all right
so let me get back to the powerpoint
so we've used this for different
projects
uh within within the arc some of the
examples are here the one project that i
will talk about
is this meditation app that we had
done a project with so this meditation
app was sent out to a bunch of different
people
and apart some of them got engaged that
is they did download the app and they
signed up
so we wanted to see what are the
different segments that
exist within the people who've
downloaded this meditation app
and we found using the app we found that
there are four different segments
and using the the insights part of the
app we found that
three of those segments so you can use
four variables
to understand how these segments are
made the first
is gender the first three of the
segments are female
they are 8800 100 female the last one is
male
then it's a risk so in health insurance
you define risk as how
sick a member is how risky he is in the
next one year so
within the females now you can bifurcate
on risks so one of them is high risk two
are low risk
within the female low risk segment now
you can bifurcate on income
one of them is higher income and one of
them is lower income so now you
understand that the people who are
downloading this app
are falling in these four buckets
and in the next iteration of the app you
can send out emails which are more
customized you can
target females who are older and lower
income
uh compared to males who are low risk
and low income and you can send out
these creatives
accordingly and hopefully you'll get a
more a higher engagement rate
so so this is how this app quickly led
to
us getting a more engaged population
more people meditating in general
and you do see impact
now the app was a hit and
the way we we can call it a hit is we
can measure it on three things we can
measure it on what users tell us so we
can use things like how many people
like this on our internal social media
page uh
what was the customer satisfaction score
so forth on us
we can also find out things that the
customer do not tell us
but we know so we can we put little
trackers within the app
which can help us uh count the number of
people who viewed the app the number of
people who uploaded their data set the
number of people who ran their analysis
and the number of people who downloaded
the end result
and we can use that as a metric to say
hey this app
is actually making a lot of impact
because
81 people 81 people have downloaded
their entire project results and i've
used them
and then there are the unknown unknowns
which is people
might have used this app and got
inspiration to do other projects and
quantifying that impact is a little
harder
all right so
the next app i want to show you is
a comorbidity or a multi-morbidity
analysis app
now as i said a co-morbidity is
two diseases so if you have two diseases
it's comorbidities
that you have if you have more than two
diseases it's multi morbidities
and the the figure on the left it shows
you
that if you have say heart condition or
if you have cancer
then your life expectancy tends to
decrease
by the number of additional health
conditions you have
so if you only had a heart disease your
life expectancy
after you first got heart disease for
say 20 years
every additional disease if you've got
diabetes along with it then it'll start
decreasing your
life expectancy and on average your life
expectancy decreases by
two years for every additional condition
you have so if you only had heart
condition
and now you've also got diabetes then
your life expectancy just decreased by
on average 1.8 years for every
additional condition you have so
multimodabilities are costly
and comorbidities are costly in fact we
also looked at our own internal data and
we found the same trend
the more diseases you have the more
number of additional diseases you have
the more costly you get in the next one
year for us
and obviously for us our main goal is to
make our members healthy and save money
in the process
so trying to find this population trying
to figure out what are the most common
multi mobilities and what are the most
expensive multimodalities what are the
most impactable multi-morbidities is
very
very uh central to our whole business
now the the analysis i'll show you uses
something called market basket analysis
or association rules people in retail
are
must be familiar with this analysis
essentially what it is is
if you had these if you've if you're say
sitting at walmart
at the cashiers register and you see
people make
these different transactions so in the
first transaction they bought an
apple a beer cocaine or sugar i'm not
sure what and then meat
and these are the different transactions
that they had
then you can call calculate three
essential metrics the first is support
so four out of the a transaction
uh contained in apple so the support is
0.5
if then you can also define confidence
that is
the people who bought an apple and a
beer
among the total number of people who
bought an apple so here
uh you were just trying to find how many
people who bought an apple
also bought a beer so that is the
confidence and finally lift is just
how much more likely are you to buy a
beer if you bought an apple
uh and if you have a lift greater than
one that that means there's a positive
association so you're more likely to buy
an apple if you bought beer
and if a lift of left less than one is
negative association
that is you're less likely to buy it now
you might have heard of stories where
they've used association rules like
uh diapers are now kept with beer
and it's because association rules show
that people
on i think tuesday or wednesday night
they tend to go out to walmart
and they'll look they will buy beer with
uh diapers more likely these are
parents who are just trying to get a
diaper and they'll be like okay i need a
beer too
and so these are used either they put
the things together or they might put
them
on opposite ends of the store so if you
go to walmart
if they found out that you need apple if
you need beer and diapers they'll put
a beer at the front of the store and
diapers at the very back
so then you will walk through the whole
store and buy more things so that's how
they use association rules in retail
now you can employ this the same logic
in healthcare as well you can define
support as the number of people who have
disease 1
and disease 2 overall so if you have 100
patients how many of them have
hypertension and diabetes
confidence is how many people who have
the two diseases
divided by the number of people who have
the disease of your interest so
of the people who are diabetic how many
of them also have hypertension
and the lift is just then how much more
likely
are you to have hypertension if you
already had diabetes if your lift is
more than one
then you're more likely if it is less
than one you're less likely
and so this is a paper that that uses
association rules
for comorbidity analysis and there have
been a lot of different papers that i've
used it including
myself i published some research on
using association rule in
comorbidity analysis
so again in the app what we did is we
put in our generic exploratory data
analysis part where you look at
missing data you do correlations things
like that
but specifically the use cases that you
can use are
you can answer questions like what are
the most common multi morbidities in the
population
what are the most expensive multi
mobilities in the population and so
forth on
so let me quickly show you the
all
app
just takes a second to load
in the meantime if you guys have any
questions please feel free to
put them in the chat
and i hope to have some time in the end
for questions as well all right
so here's the app uh again
it's uh you can you can
use this app for all of these different
parts of multi
of co-morbidity analysis you can also
find literature here on pubmed
and if you have any questions you can um
send them to me
i did upload a toy data set again and
and you can
select the this toy data set is just
all the it has like thousands of members
along with all the different diseases
that they have so if you have say
hiv aids then you your row will say one
otherwise it'll be zero so it's just
binary data for all the different
members
you can do exploratory data analysis
uh find all of these different things in
here
very similar to ones that i've shown you
before
and then you can very quickly find
things like
what are the most common comorbidities
in my data
so you just sort by support and you
would see hypertension
with hyperlipidemia so if you have more
cholesterol and your blood pressure is
high
that tends to be the most common in fact
58 percent of the members we see this
combination
so this is a combination of two what if
you're interested in a combination of
three or more diseases what are the most
common three or more conditions
then again you can very quickly sort on
this and you see that
diabetes with hyperlipidemia and
hypertension is the most common three
disease and so forth on you can very
quickly change
what what you want to find overall so it
gives you what are the most common
multi multi mobilities overall another
question you might want to
uh we use it for is in our most
expensive members and
by most expensive we define them as the
top
quartile of all the medical costs in the
next one year
so if you are in the top 25 percent of
cost in the next one year
what conditions would you have and
suppose we want to see
conditions from two all the way up to
five
then very quickly you can find if you
have historic heart disease with
hyperlympidemia and hypertension
you will be very costly for us in the in
the coming one year
uh sorry i apologize sorry you'll use
confidence uh and the most costly
conditions would be heart failure
renal failure uh in general so renal
failure tends to be you have to go on
dialysis so it's more expensive and if
you've had
heart failure more more likely you're
more likely to have certain heart
procedures which are very expensive and
that's why it's coming on top
so so this is an example of how you can
quickly
use this again you can download all of
this as an excel file
or you can just print it as well
and this tends to be very powerful in
quickly finding out what are the most
important comorbidities that you have
uh i only have 20 minutes left so i'll
skip this
the other parts i do want to show you
one
cool thing so i do have some
documentation but the cool thing that i
added in here is a chat bot
so often people have simple questions
that you have to answer again and again
a way around it is to use a chat chatbot
function
i use a dialog flow api so dialog pro is
now acquired
by google and they use natural language
processing
and you can specify certain web pages
that they can scrape for information
and then they look at keywords and give
you the replies from those web pages
you can also input your own answers that
you have
so you can even chat with it actually
but
things like
so you can ask simple questions that you
had
for example what's the maximum size of
files that i can upload
what what do i do if i get this error
things like that you can make a chat bot
it's easier than having a document that
people have to scroll scroll through
and then as i said you can add admin
tracking in here
i can track what people have been using
it and how long have they used it for
how many
and as they have done so
so so this is one example where you can
look at
comorbidities related to health
conditions you can also look at drug
combination so if you had a data set
with different drug com drugs so drugs
for hypertension or
drugs for anticoagulants or something
then you can quickly found
find out what are the most common drug
combinations that people have been using
what are the most expensive drugs that
people have been using and that's pretty
powerful
right yeah so you can use what what are
the different drug combinations that
they're using what are the
combination of diseases that most
expensive cohort of members have and so
parathon
moving on to the propensity score
matching app
all right there's quite a few
questions coming in and the slido as
well um
if maybe we could cover those in some of
those in a few minutes too that would be
awesome
sorry too yep i think i'll be done in
10 minutes
all right so propensity score matching
app as i said propensity score matching
is a
is a causal inference technique so if
you do not have
a randomized control trial and you only
have a treatment group and you want to
estimate the average treatment effect
then you would have to find people who
are who can be a synthetic control
and then you have to create for every
member in the treatment group you have
to find
a matching member who's very similar and
you can use him as a control so
say if a member was living in a
metropolitan city
he was a middle-aged male uh his
candy base candy crunch score was 50
in candy crush then you would have to
find a control member who had all of
those similar
uh uh similar characteristics so to do
that you use something called propensity
score matching it's it's a very popular
technique in quasi-experimental
trials and you can use this analysis
to do different things you can find
baseline characteristics
i apologize if this sounds a little
foreign to you
but this is more for experimental
analysis
for it's very useful in when you're
trying to run quasi experiments
so the usual process of running these
experiments is first you have to find
baseline characteristics
uh that is at the baseline how much are
my treatment
group differ different from the control
group
then you match them you find people who
are similar in the treatment
and you find matching controls and after
you found them you try to quantify
have i been able to remove all the
differences that were there
in before matching and then you also
sometimes perform something called the
sensitivity
analysis so this is something that
we uh we tend to run a lot of these
quasi experiments
and we have to do propensity score
matching quite often and for that we use
this analysis
yep and this is an app that created for
propensity score matching you can
perform exploratory analysis
you can find covariate distribution
perform the propensity score matching
you can iterate the analysis and
download formatted results again
upload uh your own data or use toy
dataset you can find all of these uh
you can find the missing data and so
forth on
and then you can finally do the
propensity score matching which which is
an alloys
with the whole analysis and download
your final results again i also have a
propensity score matching chat bot
uh very similar to the one that i showed
you before
this and in the last five minutes i do
want to talk about
one other tool which is equal
sorry to interrupt but just because you
were showing that chat bot right now
i know there were a few questions on
that um
and one of the questions was can we have
real-time customer service through this
tool
or is it just based on nlp
and then right now the chat yep sorry
sorry go ahead
and then also just if you could maybe
share a github or resource for that
chatbot later as well
sure so uh the first part of the
question
uh whether we can have a live customer
rep who can use this chatbot so i have
not done it
just because i was trying to build this
app and i was hoping to automate
all of the questions that people have i
have not but in dialogue flow from
google
you can also add that that third-party
integration
where if a question that the customer
has asked does not match with any of the
pre-listed things that then
that the the chatbot can answer then it
can
ping and ping you on a certain address
and let you know that hey transfer this
person to a live rep
so you can do that in dialogflow and a
lot of companies here they actually use
that functionality
uh besides the nlp yep and the second
part was can i share the code so for
the apps i i cannot share the code just
because
uh it belongs to the company now but i
have a lot of different other shiny apps
which use very similar methodology
uh you can find it if you look on if you
go on my github
chatranja on github you will find all my
apps you'll find
the different tableau dashboards that i
built some of the flask apps that i've
built as well
feel free to message me for anything
that you're looking for i'll
share my email address at the end and if
you're looking for some collaboration or
consultation
i would love to just just would you mind
dropping that
github into the chat here i'll put it in
right now for you
sure
all right so equal which is which stands
for
eliminate quantitative bias in
algorithms this is
an app that i built for an internal
competition and what it does is
it tries to remove bias from predictive
models
uh at cvs it's it's are now our number
one priority make sure none of the
models
have any sort of bias in them and all
our models go through this check
and we make sure that all the models are
fair equal
to to everything and to do this what we
do
what the steps that we take is uh
first when you come in you answer these
three questions
which help us find out what are the
metrics that you should be
looking for fairness so fairness you if
you've heard of fairness metrics there
are things like this part 8 impact
uh parity and so forth and answering
these three simple questions will help
you
identify what metrics are important for
me
this will pull all the data on on the
members you are interested in so there
are 11 protected attributes here in the
us
you cannot be discriminated on age
gender national origin religion
handicaps handicap status between status
pregnancy
mental and behavioral health conditions
uh so it'll pull all of this data
and then it'll check all the different
models we can build predictive models
can be regression or classification
it will check all the different steps
pre-processing
during the model build and post
processing for bias
and then it will save your results at a
specific place it will give you an
html or a word document and again
equal is built as a shiny app with
javascript so it is zero coding
language agnostic it can work with both
r up
or python models that have been uploaded
so
so equal was built to simplify this this
pathway that the data scientist has to
take
from starting from the model build all
the way up to model deployment
so let me quickly show you um
how equal looks
all right while this loads maybe i can
just switch
to the last slide which is again thank
you
and i'll take any questions you have and
again
if you're interested in working in data
science for us do email me at my
etna email which is sing s22 edna.com
and if you have any other questions on
uh code or any suggestions for
the apps that you're trying to build or
dashboards you're trying to build or if
you want to collaborate on something
please email me on my personal email
which is just my first name chatrinje
gmail.com
all right so this is how equal looks
you can come in you can take again a
very quick tour on the different parts
and um in in the app and what
what they do you can explore your data
you can evaluate the bias in your data
set you can find out
is my input data biased are my models
biased or not
and then you can also eliminate this
wise it uses techniques in
pre-processing post processing
and model build things like adversarial
de-biasing
to remove bias from your data set follow
some of the same steps that i've
shown previously where you can explore
your data you can customize your metrics
uh you can find uh different different
bias metrics
you can mitigate them and you can
download all your results
uh as well so i'll i'll stop there and
and take some of the questions that we
have awesome thank you so much jay that
that was great and so cool to see all
the applications too
i know people are right now still
putting in some questions in slido and
and if anything goes unanswered in the
time we have today
um i can definitely send those over to
jay and get the questions answered too
but the top question so far that had
been upvoted a few times was
what kind of process do you use for
updating the application
do you have any sort of defined
deployment process
so the deployment process that we use is
through rstudio connect
we have a prod version of the production
version and a dev version
the process that we use is first we
build uh
an mvp a very simple version of the app
it just does the basic
end-to-end analysis and then we upload
it to the development
server we give it to a small number of
people and we perform test and learn
so we would ask them to uh use it
in a way that they would traditionally
use it and try to and give us hints on
where they got stuck
and what can we improve and this usually
takes one month
and then we get all the feedback from
them we try to put in the most critical
elements
into the dev2 in the beta2 and then we
launch it to a slightly different
bigger population and if there are no
big hiccups then we move
this from the dev version to the broad
version where we
uh launch it throughout the company we
recalibrate all our analysis
every one and a half months early on
and after the first six months we we use
a six
months iterative calibration cycle so
every six months we would revisit it
see how the data changed has the
analysis sometimes the packages
are changed is the app working as it was
intended to work
um in the original version or not and if
there are then we
we have some downtime we optimize the
app and put it back again
so that's the cycle traditional cycle
that we use
great thanks jay um another one of the
questions that was upvoted is how do you
actually quickly set up that
tour of the shiny app i think it was in
the first shiny app that you showed
so so that's through a package called
shiny bs
you can use tool tips and these
introduction
videos there's another package i think
it's called intro js
so intro js was also it's a javascript
library
and now a lot of these javascript
libraries you will find
are packages that you can you don't have
to write javascript code
they will add it to your ui and uh so
you can
google things like shiny bs and intro js
are packaged and you will find the
packages that you can use to set up the
the
quick tour functionality
awesome and and if anyone else on the
call has other
recommendations to or things you want to
put in the chat window
that's always super helpful for people
too
another question jay was how do you
position shiny over tableau
like what would you use tableau for and
when do you decide
that it would have to be in shiny
so actually that's a great question and
just a little background so i
i was a big tableau user i actually
won the tableau massachusetts
competition three years ago
so i was a big tableau user but tableau
has limitations
uh the one limitation is that you cannot
do advanced analytics in tableau
you can do visualizations you can slice
and dice data
the the most advanced data science you
can do in tableau right now
is you can do regression so you can fit
a simple line
to your data set and that is the limit
of what you can do
but if you want to use some of the
algorithms for example if you want to
use
this segmentation or the comorbid the
association rules that i've used here
then tableau cannot do that it can make
your data look pretty
but it cannot do that analysis and to do
that analysis you will have to use
either
r or python flask
within r and python i feel like most of
the research community people like me
who were in research we tend to publish
all of our research as our packages
so you would usually see things coming
out of research going into our first
and if they're very useful for industry
there'll be a
python package that is now copying that
our package
so with shiny or flask you can use the
latest and greatest data science advance
analytics
along with visualization the
visualization might not look as neat as
say tableau
just because it's been designed by like
professionals but it will still be more
advanced you can do these analysis
which are more complicated in our
thank you jay that's really helpful i
know you know that question
seems to come up on quite a few meetups
too
so maybe it'd be helpful for us to even
have a full
a longer talk on that too
another question i know we have just a
few more minutes here but
shiddage asked hey jay have you
encountered scenarios where you want to
run clustering on big data sets
upwards of 10 million rows from within
shiny
uh so so the one thing i would say is
that most of the shiny apps that
i've shown you it tends to run on
smaller data sets
for bigger data sets shiny for for the
current for
the knowledge that the limited knowledge
that i have and the use that i have had
uh the scalability tends to be an issue
later on
now recently there have been new
packages that you can use to parallelize
uh the analysis and you can use delay
methodology so you can
you don't have to perform the analysis
uh
right then you can use a catch or you
can delay the analysis later on and that
makes the flow
the user experience faster but if you
are trying to use
big data analysis then shiny might not
be
the best idea or it might be maybe i
don't know
but for those kind of analysis trying to
build a live app
you tend to work better with some of the
other big data methodologies
so if you're running your analysis on
say spark
then you can use things that that go on
top of a spark analysis and you can
use dashboarding there to analyze those
process flows and they'll be much more
efficient
and they won't bug your users uh than a
slower app which tends to block people a
lot
thank you and for one of the the last
questions today i see tony asked
could you talk about the bias detection
app is there any public info
on that so there is a lot of free
public information out there ibm came up
with something called uh
ibm 360 fairness 360
which is a comprehensive set of tools
built by people who are actually
researchers and professors at university
uh very extensive package it's both an r
and a python package
ai 360 which for me
the one thing with that package is it
tends to be confusing just because they
put in so many
different details or a user who just
wants to check his model for bias
i would be a little confused on what
metrics should i use
and what met what what does actually
bias mean
another pack so google has come out with
their own
fairness package it's a it's a web app
that you can quickly use import your
data set and find out whether
say there is a race or gender bias in
your data set or not
so there are different methodologies
that are out there for your own specific
customized use case
i would say uh you would you would have
to actually study the material
and then then come up with what is the
most useful for you
but a lot of literature out there
great thank you so much i know we're
just getting to the end of our
time that we had scheduled today so just
want to say thank you so much jay for
the awesome presentation